c'est pas facile de prendre un nouveau
départ
quand on pense sans arrêt au passé
[Musique]
on a des comptes à régler toi et moi il
faut qu'on parle
[Musique]
mais je suis un homme neuf
will bettelheim vous avez un dossier en
étant oui mais vous n'êtes pas sur les
réseaux sociaux est bon c'est quand même
un peu bizarre
il paraît qu'on se crée son propre et
l'est
en fonction des gens qui nous entourent
et
salut toi y avait ravi de vous
rencontrer la vie
je devrais peut-être partir mais là
maintenant je n'en avais aucune envie
[Musique]
quels sont tes intentions avec ma soeur
citons mais parfait parfait
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on dise n'a
fallu que tu recommences je me trompe
sujet de ton ex c'est ça
elle a vraiment fait souffrir
[Musique]
si le thème comme un fou c'est la chose
la plus dangereuse qui soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas laisser la situation se
détériorer
rien ne va plus sur toi bon
by me guilloux
[Musique]
sauf un siège au irish times relations
q